Joining us
now, Republican
Congressman Ken
Buck from Colorado,
who has voted for McCarthy so far.
Congressman Buck, thanks for joining us.
You said something to Kevin McCarthy
about what needs to happen going forward.
Tell us what you said.
Well, I've had a number of conversations
with Kevin,
and I've just basically told him
that at some point
this needs to break loose.
He either needs to make a deal
to bring the 19 or 20 over or
he needs to step aside
and give somebody else
a chance to do that.
I don't know what that timeframe is,
but it makes sense
that at some point
today, we
we are able to move forward in a way that
we elect a speaker.
Unfortunately, the Democrats
won't agree
to a motion to adjourn
so that Republicans can meet the rebels.
The 20 group
that that is opposing
McCarthy won't agree
to a motion to adjourn.
So we're going to keep going
through this exercise on the floor.
The smart thing to do is to
get together,
have a
conversation, choose
somebody and let's move forward.
Right.
I mean, one would have thought that
that would have happened already.
It's not like
it was a mystery
that this vote was coming up
and somehow
Kevin McCarthy was caught unawares.
I mean, we knew this vote was happening.
And it seemed very clear
that whether it was five votes
or 20 votes,
Kevin McCarthy
was not going to have the votes.
Do you think he's going to lose on this
fifth ballot?
Well, of course,
of course the
the 20 have not budged
and the Democrats
are going to vote for him.
So we're pretty much going
to get the same vote
this time as we got the last four time.
So your message to
Kevin McCarthy is basically
we need to fish or cut bait. We need to.
If you can't get to 218 or 217,
whatever the threshold is,
we need to find someone else.
Who might that be?
Well,
I think the next in line is Steve
Scalise,
and I don't know
if Steve gets more or less.
I think that
at some point
we've got to start looking at the rules
and the committee assignments
and other things
and just get back to the basics
of what people
what their self-interest is in this case
and meet some of those interests
and hopefully get the votes
Hey, Congressman, it's Dana Bash.
Are you confident that if Steve Scalise
were nominated,
that he would be palatable to
enough of the 20
who won't vote for Kevin McCarthy?
So I think you need to break the 20 down.
There are a few of those 20
that just aren't going to vote
for Kevin McCarthy,
but would vote for somebody else.
There are some of the others
in that 20
who want changes in the rules
and there are some others
that care about policy.
And so I think if Steve meets
those three needs
he will be able to move forward
and take the speakership.
And Congressman Buck,
this is Abby Phillip.
Thanks for being here.
My question is about what you just said
about the timing of this.
You said that by today
you need to see some indication
of where this is going to go.
Do you think that by today
Kevin McCarthy needs to make that deal
or make a decision to move
out of the speaker's race?
I think at some point today,
the conference as a whole
needs to make a decision.
I think what's what's happening right now
is people are getting worn down.
You're starting to get
some conflict,
open conflict
on the floor
as well as behind closed doors.
I think that conflict isn't healthy.
And I think,
you know, the moderates are talking about
threats that they may work
with the Democrats on somebody
the 20 are saying that they're not moving
no matter what.
At some point, people have to realize
that we've got to choose a speaker
and move forward.
The American people sent us here
to get the work done.
Do you think Kevin McCarthy is hearing
your message?
Is he willing to step aside
if he loses on a fifth vote,
on a six vote on a seventh vote?
He's been preparing and hoping for this
his whole life.
His argument
might be, look,
I still have more votes
than any other Republican,
although certainly not more votes
than any one else running
because Hakeem
Jeffries keeps beating him.
Do you sense any willingness to,
in your view, face the music?
Well, look, Hakeem Jeffries is losing
also Let's be honest,
there isn't a winner
until somebody gets in to 18.
I just think he has more votes,
that's all.
He has more votes,
but he doesn't have the ability
to become speaker in this Congress.
So Kevin McCarthy,
I think,
will make the decision at some point.
And what's going to happen
and what what should happen sooner
rather than later
is some of the senior members,
some of the cardinals on appropriations,
the committee chairmen,
some of the other folks
that have been here
a long time, have supported
Kevin, are going to have to have
that private conversation with them
that it doesn't make sense
and we need to move forward.
Do you have any sense, sir,
that that's actually going to happen?
I have a sense it's common sense,
but I don't have a sense that it is.
No one has whispered in my ear
that it's about that.
Well, you've seen
what's been happening on the floor.
I think common sense
left the room a while ago.
But just real quick,
I want to follow up on the comment
that you made about Steve Scalise.
You told Manu Raju
and you're saying now that he is
probably the
consensus candidate,
what would he need to do to get.
I realize the 20 should be splitting
into various camps, but at the end
he would need to 18.
How would he have to
what would he have to do to get that?
So I think that what Steve needs to do is
we have to have a break
whether it's this evening
or at some point.
And I think Steve just needs to sit down
with each individual,
talk to them about what they want.
Now, the problem is once
you make a commitment
to a conservative in the caucus,
then there's going to be a moderate
who says, wait a second,
I've been waiting for that
committee chairmanship
and I've been waiting for that
subcommittee chairmanship.
And so it is it's almost a zero sum game.
You start giving to one
side, you're taking away from the other.
Congressman Buck,
before you go,
one last question,
which is how many votes do you think is
enough for this process to go on assuming
that Kevin McCarthy continues
to lose votes,
which he has been in the last few votes?
I mean, this is the Fifth right now.
What's the maximum
you think would be acceptable all before?
There's a step to try
to find somebody else
that that will get to 17 or to 18.
So if I knew
that I would be on a flight to Vegas
and I'd be putting my money
down on the table, I have no idea.
I think it's going to be in the next two
or three votes that the nerves are frayed
enough
that people come together
and make a decision
And are you going to continue
voting for McCarthy,
or is your vote
possibly going to shift
to a different candidate?
If it's Steve Scalise or a present vote
Yeah.
So I am voting on this vote
for Kevin McCarthy.
Stay tuned
and I'll let you know
what I'm going to be doing in the future.
All right.
So this is the last time he can count
on your vote.
This ballot right now, the fifth one.
Congressman Ken Buck,
Colorado, thank you so much.
Really appreciate your time.
Good luck to you and your caucus of.